pleased to have Bleacher Report's own um
one of the finest in the association
media none other than howard back here
back here on the show how are you Howard
I'm doing all right rich how are you now
hanging in there hanging in there I did
see you the other day have you really
not had a haircut
during the quarantine at all how long
have you gone out or not
March 13th was my last haircut this is I
think the longest I've gone in my adult
life without a haircut it's looking
looking really wild I'm uh I'm
approaching like before I finally got
rid of the de lockdown beard because it
was just too much I was approaching like
Saul Berenson of homeland levels where
he'd been where he'd been like kidnapped
and like in a cell somewhere you know in
in Pakistan for like you know three
months that's what you had bad so I
leave covered to the Saul Berenson beard
but the hair is a disaster not to ruin
it for anybody but the Saul Berenson
character in homeland played by the
great Mandy Patinkin if you ever noticed
and homeland viewers will knows Saul was
always walking he's always going some
recipes walking aggressively
aggressively walking through an office
walking to a phone while he's constantly
walking he doesn't stay ITA's in stain
still he's constantly walking now if you
notice always angry I know I always he's
a busy man and he's got urgent matters
again you're very Saul Berenson like so
I'm glad you got rid of the beard and
you're here on the here on the show
where do things stand right now in the
Association we're ready to tip-off is
that what's happening right now what do
you got for me I have been trying to
preach like not caution but caveats ever
since they started down this road of
we're going to restart the season it's
going to be in a bubble it's going to be
at the Disney campus and everybody says
okay great we're back we're back let's
talk like what you know who's the
favorites who's been and and I've just
every time I've tried to pump the brakes
just saying listen there's a plan but
that doesn't mean we're actually you
know we're a long way from there like
three weeks ago whenever they first
started to roll this out we were still
like almost too
from a start date as you and I talked
today we are still what like five six
weeks or something from when they'll
play the first game or hope to play the
first game and as I've said all along a
lot can change well that has changed in
the last three weeks certain parts of
the country including Orange County
Florida where the Disney Wide World of
Sports Complex is is gotten really bad
the the you know worst surge of cases
that we've seen in months
so that certainly would give me pause
whether that gives Adam Silver pause or
the players union pause or anyone else
associated with this restart plan we'll
see I have no doubt that it does like
I'm sure that they are monitoring this
and are not thrilled with what they're
seeing unfold but at the same time you
know I don't know what the threshold is
how bad does it have to get how many
hospitalizations per day or how many
deaths how many cases what what's the
the tipping point for them to say you
know what it's just not worth it
I don't know if there's a number I don't
know if this is just by feel or if one
day they're epidemiologists that they're
consulting walk in well they don't walk
into any any offices at this point but
they pull at them on the zoom call and
say Adam we think you got to call this
thing off I don't know what that tipping
point is but I assume that there is one
and you know but look right now it's
it's it's all you know if it's all ago
and there are players that we've seen
day by date deciding not to go it's a
hit but it's only a handful did you know
the league is viable the stars are all
going as far as we can tell and I think
chances all this still probably happens
unless things get really catastrophic in
Central Florida
well I mean just like everything powered
kovat is finding the weak spots in
everything whether it's our health care
system or people's relationships just
seriously uh you know not to go too deep
here but it is real-world stuff that
that that that kovat seems to find the
weak spots people's feelings of
loneliness and it just keeps on putting
the pressure on you know trevor ariza
saying he's not coming because he's got
visitation rights for only one month
this year and it's during the bubble
time he's not going I mean this is this
is real-life stuff are you hearing any
more stories of maybe people coming over
from Europe don't want to come because
you know Western Europe the European
Union seems to have gotten a much better
handle on this than our country what are
you what are you hearing about players
cuz that's to me the way that this
doesn't go that that that whatever plan
they have for kovat and their their
health and safety protocols they feel is
ready to just just gotta get everyone
there and then they can zip up the
community there and in in in Disneyworld
what are you hearing from other players
that say I don't want to go for whatever
reason an agent told me a couple weeks
back was I don't remember what the
number he threw out was and I don't even
know if it was just an estimate on his
part just based on conversations but
they were like I think a few dozen
players who had girlfriends or wives
expecting children this summer or
sometime between you know now and maybe
when the bubble ends and they were
saying listen just on that alone guys
are not going to want to be cut off from
their pregnant girlfriend's pregnant
wives that like that's a perfectly
reasonable thing and he said keep an eye
out for that in terms of guys coming
back from Europe I mean I haven't heard
anything or from around the world I
haven't heard anything along those lines
terms of just you know that the u.s. is
in a worse off shape than a lot of other
places but look anything you would or I
could could think of that might crop up
as a concern the spike in cases in
Florida
any general concern about exposing
yourself travel you know what it might
mean for your family you know just even
just injury concerns because they've all
been off for so long that nobody's in
basketball shape and they're only gonna
have a few weeks to ramp up this is like
nothing else they've ever done because
in a normal offseason you have access to
gyms and you're still playing pickup
ball and you still can work with your
trainer this is like nothing else we've
that these players have been through a
lot of them haven't even had access to
the basket to shoot at and they're gonna
jump back in play eight glorified
exhibitions for some of these teams
these feeding games that are going to
determine you know the you know the one
through eight note Eastern West and
maybe determine whether a couple teams
can sneak into the eighth season in the
east
they're gonna play a couple weeks of
these these these games and they're
gonna jump into playoffs and so you know
Davos burton's of the Wizards decide to
opt out of this whole thing because he's
heading toward free agency and the first
major payday of his career cuz he's out
had just had a breakout season and has
had a couple of ACLs like what you know
of course he wouldn't want to risk that
under these circumstances I so any of
these concerns they're all valid and
these are these are personal decisions
basically these guys are making I don't
blame any one of them if they decide to
opt out and they're look they're giving
up their paycheck for those games to do
it so they're willing to make that
sacrifice and then I think any you know
people just need to respect that
Howard Becca bleacher report here on the
Rich Eisen show and so in terms of
players that are going there and the
seedings and everything like that hasn't
changed right we're still we're still on
with those eight games those are those
are gonna be played for sure nothing's
changed on everything that we heard from
a few weeks ago yeah yeah nothing's
changed but I wouldn't rule out the
possibility that it changes I mean I've
been in the camp all along of don't
bring any more teams than you have to
because every team is more bodies and
more bodies means more potential risk
and it's it's you know it's just a math
question it's just a probabilities
question so if it gets really bad in
Orlando does the NBA decide you know
we're not calling it off but man forget
the 22 teams let's just go 16 so they'll
play a few they'll do round-robin
exhibition to get everybody back in a
game shape and then we'll jump into the
playoffs forget the the seeding games
let's just bring the 80 in the East and
the eight in the West who were you know
I had the top spots when we suspended
they they could theoretically do that I
don't think they will because you know
everybody's bought into a certain you
know schedule or a plan and there's
money attached to that plan and there
are teams that are you know have you
know everything in the works to go I
don't think they'll call that off but
that would be one way of doing this
would be just to streamline this a
little and look they don't have to play
best-of-seven every round it wasn't that
long ago that we had a best-of-five
first round and actually it was really
great
you could you could streamline this you
could decide to spend less time
so there are a number of measures they
could take if they want to try to
minimize the burden on the players and
personnel if they want to minimize the
risk a little bit more but you know as
of right now I think it's full speed
ahead with with this plan with 22 teams
and folk best of seven series and a very
long time down there because there's a
billion dollars at stake what are you
hearing about coaches I mean pop is
seventy right I mean what are you
hearing about that I mean the Union
players and the Association is one thing
here but what are you hearing about
coaches who might be in the vulnerable
or at risk community the case that the
league has made and I've heard you know
you know various people who work you
know on the medical side within the
league make us case two is that
everybody once they get there will be
safer there in the NBA bubbled and they
would be back at home because you did
the you know biggest think about pop for
instance you know Texas is a place I
don't know about San Antonio in
particular or where he lives within that
at that area but Texas is one of the
places where cases are really spiking
now they're spiking in Florida but if
you are you know the whole point of the
bubble is that you are tested every day
you're not encountering anybody outside
of the bubble you're not leaving the
NBA's campus and so you have you know in
theory less risk less encounters with
random people who could be asymptomatic
carriers now the Disney employees are
going to come and go but they're not
supposed to have any interaction with or
get anywhere near anybody who is in the
NBA bubble players coaches or otherwise
so in theory you're safer in theory but
if I were 70 years old an NBA coach if I
were pop if I were Mike D'Antoni was a
few years younger than that by were
Alvin Gentry I don't know it would give
me pause I you know as safe as it might
be as many precautions as they're taking
I don't know that I dress I think I just
want to like just barricade myself in my
house until there's a vaccine I just
don't know that I want to take that kind
of risk but you guys are their
competitors and they're there they're
married to their jobs
coaches are different than you and me
like they're just these guys they're gym
rats like there's a reason
still doing this at his age he doesn't
need to he could have retired long ago
but you know in Alvin Gentry Mike
D'Antoni of both been on the record very
stubbornly or adamantly saying
emphatically saying like we're going
like we'll be fine couple more minutes
left with Bleacher Report's senior NBA
rider howard back we were discussing
this on our monday show how howard about
pumping in crowd noise we're seeing
we're seeing the Premier League have an
ability to watch the games watch the
matches with crowd noise and with
somebody using their the EA Madden
sports sound effects that they have
accrued from real matches or overseas
again this is not a facetious question
because ask my my EP Don Bowie to put up
on our screen right here the the Western
Conference standings when you look at
the Western Conference standings the
Lakers sitting atop at 1:00 and who
knows who's gonna be eight but just
again jazz Thunder that go into Utah and
winning a game going to Oklahoma City
and winning a game in a playoff series
is monster difference right so are they
just gonna just say it's the same I mean
in Game one let's say Game seven of a
playoff series and I'm being serious
here between the Jazz and the Thunder
goes down can they pump in the noise in
a way to make it louder for for the
Thunder to actually communicate in a
timeout because it would be figuratively
in Utah I mean like are they gonna try
in any way shape or form mimic a home
court advantage that might even come
into play if it's Lakers Clippers I
don't know what they're going to do I
think that there's a strong case to be
made that they should do what you're
saying as weird as it might be as
manufacturers it might be and there's
going to be a psychological disconnect
because visually you look around and
there's a handful of people in the gym
but but your ears are hearing you know
the semblance of your home crowd or the
away crowd and you could absolutely
manufacture it like there's no question
the technology exists in the audio just
to do this where you could have MVP
chance when LeBrons at the foul line if
it's a Laker home game
but you could have him getting booed and
taunted and everything else when it's a
road game against the Memphis Grizzlies
in the first round you could do that you
could have the the cheers the boos
everything to simulate it will it have
the same psychological effect will it
actually replicate a home court
advantage when you know exactly they
you're still in the same place it's the
same court you're standing on two days
ago when it was a road game and now it's
a home game but it I I I don't know I
don't know what the answer to that is
and I don't know what the NBA will
ultimately do I do strongly suspect that
they will not allow it to just be quiet
because the home audience will hear too
much the reporters who are in the stands
will hear too much and they don't want
to hearing all the things that are said
between players or between coaches and
players during the course of the game
and also between players and refs and I
mean that would be you know quite
something for us to be able to pick up
and hear and isn't Cuban talking about
letting the fans at home cheer and
having that actually affect what's going
on in the arena isn't that already
something that I've heard him say I mean
I that's funny because I'd I'd suggested
the same thing I had Harrison Barnes on
my podcast a few weeks back and we were
talking about ways to do this and I was
I said something like that like I would
love to see like the world's largest
zoom call right yeah you could split it
between fans of each team but I don't
know make it make it 3/4 one teeny of
the home team and one-fourth the other
and everybody could share from a home
like I think that would be phenomenal it
would be it would be real it would be
live it would be a little strange but at
least it would be not canned I again I
don't know what the league is is
planning on that side of things they
haven't quite gotten there yet they've
had bigger things attack no no I'm sure
last one for you Howard what about the
media are you going yet what's the
conversation you're having with many of
your colleagues how many how many people
are gonna raise their hands or have a
parent company that's gonna pay for a
room at for three months to send
somebody what are we hearing about on
the media front of covering and being
part of this there will be a lot more
public probably later today but I can't
say all of it right now be
because I'm part of the pro basketball
writers board that has been working with
the league on trying to to do this um
what I can tell you is what already
leaked a week or two ago and there's
going to be a small number very small
number of reporters who will be in the
bubble itself so that means you're
committed for full 90 days or you're
your outlet at least will be committed
for the full 90 days and there's going
to be a possibility to swap out at some
point but you might be committed for the
full you know three months of sequester
basically and you'll be under all the
same restrictions but with all without
any of the perks that the NBA prepares
and things are going to get and it means
having your meals delivered to you it
means getting tested every day it means
no freedom of movement so to answer part
of your question no I'm not going to go
to the bubble like I just it's not
justifiable it's not it does no there's
not enough of a payoff it doesn't make
sense I have a family I did you know
somebody else wants to do it more power
to them but it's not for me are you
hearing then are you hearing are you
hearing members of your of your
community that are similar or different
I mean what do you what's the general
sense I've heard many more of my friends
say no to the to the possibility of the
bubble then then then maybe I'm a couple
are kind of gung-ho like they like the
idea that's just a weird experience that
I mean listen it it is a great story if
I were 20 years younger and single Shore
30 years younger and single nice um you
know yeah different stage of my career I
would have said yeah why not yes screw
it I'll be fine
give me some video games in a few good
books and I'll go and sequester for
three months and I'll write this amazing
story about this really weird NBA
partial season in it in the middle of
Disney World but no for a lot of people
a lot of my friends who have who have
kids who who cover the NBA nobody wants
to do that and so I don't know how many
people will actually volunteer for it
but again it's a small number that the
NBA is even going to allow in any way
right I'll be interested to see if they
get to the max number there's going to
be a second tier of reporters who can go
down not be in the bubble stay anywhere
you want but you're not getting tested
by the NBA most likely and you're not
getting any access the only thing you're
getting
is to go into the gym watch the game
from a distance in the stands and that's
it all your all your interviews will be
via zoom but even the people who are in
the bubble interviews are mostly going
to be either a socially distance press
conference or via zoom so it's there's
just not much payoff or incentive to be
there and everything is going to be
streamed so that people can cover it
from home and the vast vast vast
majority of print reporters who cover
this league will be covering the bubble
from home not in the bubble and not in
Orlando and then I guess the question
will be them what happens for the the
following season but I guess one step at
a time and we'll see how it goes and um
you know I appreciate the call Howard
really do mad now rich always a pleasure
and yeah let's hope by the time we get
to next season whenever that is maybe
December that there's a little bit more
ability to return to normal and that
teams can play in their home markets but
I'm not that optimistic at the moment
that that's going to be the case given
where we are in this country at this
moment know I know that we never know
what happens in therapeutics and all
that stuff in the meantime you're gonna
have to get a haircut before December
Howard you just you know just to go
outside sit in the chair outside yeah
New York City just started reopening and
shops finally reopened this week but we
finally bailed out of New York and and
we're up in the Hudson River Valley okay
just we needed a change of location
change of scenery but things would have
been open for a while here so I'm
optimistic that sometime in the next few
days when I'm not working I will find an
open barber shop and I will get this
thing under control and I will cease
being so bare
[Laughter]
you take care our thanks to the call you
got it that's Howard Becker leach
reporting hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here